you please tell the camera the
stationary astronauts got me
yo stationary astronauts [ __ ] figured
it out I don't know how but the [ __ ]
haircut and everything mr. banner Chuck
yes sir I am so appreciative if I dude I
signed the dotted line with nothing yes
and through grit and will I was that was
the big first domino that fell the big
first domino was Zack Nadler getting
back to me a day early solacing yeah so
everyone was on Christmas break I got
the automated email back saying that
they were gonna get back to me on jus
January 3rd yes he got back to me on
January 2nd and I had already hit him
with because we have a cool thing going
on here we have we double in population
on a monthly basis due to visitors alone
and he likes his story and I don't know
if any of this was getting relayed to
you now but then it just came down to
man my pitch game was on point and I
really cuz he's a tough filter because
we've got a thousand people a month that
don't have the economics that are like
pitch it we'd like we don't like we
don't lock updates like mm-hmm
and you also had to give a deposit at
some point bro the deposit was the
toughest part had to be um so like he
actually dropped it in half for me good
Zack big shout out to you Nadler like
straight-up Wow
like he honestly Nadler made it happen
because he doesn't he must have really
believed in you he he did and I am I
like it was just so crazy because I knew
I was working him I knew I was pissing
him off he's like he's New York state of
mind no games dog and like 1%
unfortunately like money doesn't grow on
trees here in the Midwest you know what
I'm saying and like so what was the
first domino after that um it was
Kathleen Harrington the president of the
Chamber of Commerce believed to me love
and she I got to sit down dude out of
fate I got to sit down and she just like
cut me an initial check and it was
nothing big
just a $5,000 check that's boy I got my
it got my soul gb leverage yeah bro gave
me leverage and then um my boy Marcus
Cheryl's who's our punt returner for the
Minnesota Vikings she's like you know
what man
I got you dog I got you and he cut me
that that deposit check and I'm blind
faith um good and but he's my point
guard he we graduated together you just
met his brother and sister-in-law in the
in the meet and greet and that was the
first domino dog because then that got
Naylor off my back but this is the crazy
thing is after I cut the check turned
onto the first deposit it was only 25%
so we did it on blind faith immediately
DJ is hitting me up like yo you got the
rest of that deposit now like oh [ __ ]
dog and they just kept giving me more
time more time Wow because they believed
in it I know any of this stuff I told
that or nobody
only take 50% deposits and don't [ __ ]
around on impact I don't need you
closing my schedule for a day and then
coming back and being like it's not
gonna happen
yeah well listen he he clearly saw
something new and he was right I'm Tony
pretty eyes and a [ __ ] up haircut yeah
I'm telling you no I wish I had that
hair right Caleb no but okay so we were
just moving and then the Hustle just
kept going and uhm as the momentum
started picking up these on
powers-that-be these these heads started
believing in me cuz they started catch a
win like I don't know who Gary is but
this [ __ ] Knicks got some energy
to him and he's really hustling like
he's I sacrificed my job of Reebok like
all my other jobs dawg I had a baby
throughout this process I have a four
month old daughter
that's like dog like my hustle is on a 1
right now I get it you know and like now
it's real and it's here yes is it
emotional for it to be real it is
because I'm gonna see in your head and
just an imagination to like actually see
it in real life is crazy
yeah and once I met you I was like oh
[ __ ] this is my guy right here it's just
real you know but the thing is is I yeah
was that a worry a little bit it was
regular work there's all this time and
all this capital like what if I was but
you kind of warned him that I was cool
right yep yeah so you were a little bit
more
right yes that makes sense but I gambled
I'm taking a loss but at the same time
dude it's a box in the neck bro next
event you're sick yeah we're gonna be
able to leverage us in perpetuity girl
you're gonna take a million screenshots
of me wearing this [ __ ] t-shirt yeah
[ __ ] I mean it's you've won yeah and
that's kind of what we're trying to do
Gary is like just use this to propel us
because we're already working on our
second installment next year what kind
of sense and by the way whoever your Big
Dawg is if she or he wants to talk to me
on the phone of who you guys are and
we're gonna do it thank you brother
welcome oh that's the [ __ ] ultimate
endorsement % thank you so much
one minute cuz my times yeah but we'll
be like yo Tim Farriss [ __ ] do
it yeah absolutely dude I love Tim dude
4-hour workweek shout it out so then the
the ball was just rolling and then as
these powers-that-be started riding with
us it just got started gaining steam but
the thing is is this is kind of what we
want you to talk about on stage to like
money is good here but consumerism is
[ __ ] they started hanging weak on
stage I know we're doing this in a
podcast but I want to ask you there's 40
minutes of me I'm up there for how long
you're up there for another 35 minutes
after that in what format Q wait a
minute QA and then we're gonna present
you with the worthy warrior award why
don't we do why don't we do 35 40 or
like we'll figure it out but I think you
should come on and ask me the first two
or three questions before we would open
up because I want to be honest with you
like cuz I want this to be great for you
I'm gonna black out up there okay so
you're gonna be like yo like [ __ ] on
everybody and get them [ __ ] focused
on something and I'm gonna like save one
thing and go down a path and be like how
the thief basically here's how it works
and we look Gary go out there and say
yellow banana I'm not cool and I go out
there and basically talk about chocolate
kangaroos dolls and her like you know
what happened I'm like yo I told you so
I'm gonna go out there and try to bring
the most value yeah but I think you can
definitely come in and be like hey let's
bring this down to earth about us and
ask three questions and then I'll give
answers I think you'll get what you need
does that make sense as we go on after
week after I like I think when I stop my
keynote uh-huh I'm gonna transition to
QA
you should come out and like do the
first two or three quick gotcha brother
got fair absolutely I think it'd be a
good look for you got it and then this
way what cuz I'm gonna talk Mac Road
value mm-hmm and you come in and be like
yo why don't you bring this down to
earth I got a couple questions about
town you said I'm gonna absolutely
that's a good look now armed to talk
about kind of what drove me to bring you
here yes it was really I grew up slang
in baseball cards yeah basketball cards
was my it was my repertoire and I was
you know part Matson Garnett's I was
obsessed with Garnett and Mari Kobe
Bryant rookie cards you know what I'm
saying I was obsessed with Shaquille
O'Neal and then it turned into learning
the power of trade value you know and
then I was also slaying in newspapers
shout out the newspapers yep you know
back when print was hot back in the 90s
some metal and back of my back so then
it was just like you bro early 2000s hit
and I grew up in a family of small
business owners but it was like I was
never handed anything it's like no
[ __ ] you're coming to wash
dishes and bussed tables for $50 a night
you know just for shits and giggles you
know so like I started I started once I
started working on my own every winter
say I'd get laid off because we get
harsh winters here I'm slanging sewing
purses for hippie chicks one for fifty
two for eighty they get to pick out the
fabric and beads you know and it was
just like the steady grind of like and I
never knew who Gary Vaynerchuk was and
then once I started learning about you
probably a year and a half two years ago
it was internet scrolling scrolling on
some timeline and it was like this
[ __ ] speaking my language and
it's the language it's beyond your New
York state of mind it's like he's on my
wavelength or I'm on his wavelength and
I'm definitely um obviously a decade
behind him but after 32 I'm 30 30 yes
so I'm behind him but at the same time I
was like you turn 30 in February third
so did you feel anything turning 30 or
no um I actually it was yeah of course I
did of course I did but I got a baby on
the way so it's like I'm growing up
regardless you know what I'm saying I
got married last year and I'm growing up
regardless and I knew when I was 30 I
better have my purpose dialed in that's
what I was worried about is
I gotta have my purpose dialed in and my
purpose in this life is connecting
people you know what I'm saying and
having skills having conversations and
it all comes from just the confidence
people ask me dude how did you get Gary
Vaynerchuk confidence yeah that's all it
was you decided listen something you
need things to work out sometimes yeah
you know like Nadler for whatever reason
was cool with giving you like a discount
on on deposits which is something that's
like pretty hard like I trust him so he
can do whatever the [ __ ] he wants but he
knows like we don't do it and then like
Kathleen Kathleen what's that her name
she gave you the shot she could've said
no I mean just I believe in that [ __ ] if
you if you understand what you're trying
to do it gives you a North Star and then
you try to figure it out I don't know
how to say like it's just a lot better
and and money can't be the North Star
you just can every single day when I'm
going on live I'm talking about how
lucky I am how lucky we are um to just
be in the position we're in was there
ever a point Gary where you look back
and I was like man I'm so lucky to have
the mom I had yeah um the dad I had or
the the setup I had where I got to help
build my dad's business I think I think
like in that way like literally doing
that probably probably 42 probably 7 8 9
years ago but I lived my life as if my
whole life I always lived grateful I
just never thought of it that way I
always lived thankful grateful
appreciative lack of entitlement my
whole life but I didn't think about it I
wasn't psychoanalyzing myself when
people started paying attention to me
after I wrote some books and gave some
speeches it made me ask why like why was
that good on stage why do people like me
like why was this happening why do
people hate me why did people not like
me right away like why would these
things happening and that's when I
stumbled probably you know 7 to 10 years
ago I'm like ooh boy am i grateful for
my circumstance you know you start
understanding you know a lot of people
talk about white privilege or American
male priviledge I think it's a
mental-health game I'm just privileged
to have my [ __ ] together mentally like
self-esteem self-awareness gratitude
these things really added up to a good
concoction that has really worked for me
that train of thought is a gift there
are so many people that that way of
thought is a gift there are so many
people who will go their entire life and
not even know what the hell empathy is
100% you know not even know the word yes
some people that's one of the biggest
reasons I'm pushing it so hard yeah you
know just by even people acknowledging a
word like empathy or gratitude I mean
dudes that we're trying to kill it
didn't use words like empathy and
gratitude seven years ago like look just
like seeing like sleeved up like rad
dudes roll up to me like you know
kindness dawg I'm like it's just so
honestly I genuinely believe my great
legacy potentially may be that I made
emotionally intelligent soft skills
alpha you know you'll never believe this
is a super interesting to me the fact
that pink was a boys color and blue was
a girl's color back in the day is kind
of how I think about gratitude empathy
kindness I'm like I'm gonna trick these
young [ __ ] dogs into like thinking
this [ __ ] is cool and then one day in 50
years people gonna be like the alpha
male traits are like gratitude and
kindness and if I could pull that off
then it's like ah then you can like I
think a lot about my legacy and I
actually think the that is probably the
best bet I have right now I can
penetrate young alpha males most people
that can penetrate young alpha males
talk about cliche young alpha male [ __ ]
and it's very like bang chicks like when
like that stuff and I can get I I don't
know honestly it's a very interesting
thing to watch even for me to watch it
outside of my own self I'm like am I
really making gratitude cool it's it's
it's an incredible feeling right now for
me it's a it's a combination of honing
my skills understanding Instagram and
YouTube at its apex believing in it you
know I think
thing I always was was very sensitive I
cried a lot as a kid I always stood up
for kids that got bullied to my
detriment in popularity I I like I'm
very emotional like I had this like big
date in high school to Lion King and
cried when the [ __ ] dad died right in
front of the girl like I've got that in
me and like never really gave a [ __ ] and
like just and it and it's really working
out like it's really fun for my high
school and junior high friends grammar
school even to that degree friends like
give me dabs it's been really
interesting it's been really interesting
to see them come out of the Woodworks
and like defend me even like people I
didn't know super well like just like
jump in and be like no dude like don't
be a dick like I knew him in junior high
and he [ __ ] like was nice you know
just it just really it's been really
very cool to watch actually do you
believe in the zodiac calendar I don't
now I'll tell you this maybe I just
actually don't know like I don't are we
talking like Scorpio yes yeah so like
I'm a Scorpio and like I feel like I've
got Scorpio personal I don't know what
Scorpio things are but like the whole
stinging and like like you know like I
don't know like probably there's got to
be some fun truth to it I'm just not
educated enough to know if I do or I
don't and I don't grab a toy gravitate
towards figuring it out oh it's okay so
as we enter the Aquarian age that's a
feminine energy and what you have done
with the female brand as well as how
you're pushing empathy you're pushing
feminine energy on the planet right now
that's really positive you know it's
funny I used to say that and now I'm
asking myself is empathy and all these
things actually feminine or did we kind
of position them that way
and I feel like that's where I've landed
which is they're neutral energies in my
mind though I might be wrong cuz I'm not
educated and this is not what I really
look at but I will say this something's
definitely happening for real and it's
[ __ ] amazing and it makes me feel
incredible and if God forbid I even pull
off 10% of what I think I could pull off
I'm making so much positive impact in
the world a woman up here said that she
was laid off from QVC did you capture it
did you see the woman you got it out
like you saw her I got caught a little
bit
yeah she ya good can you give it to me
cuz it's a real nice moment she was like
look I got laid off and I was like
sitting on my couch to press for two
three months and that [ __ ] Monday like
[ __ ] like like you know make Monday your
[ __ ] she was like that changed my life
she just got like and that's crazy like
I don't know what else to say like like
I don't need anybody ever on earth again
to say anything nice just that woman
today here in Russia here that minute
worth the whole [ __ ] time you're
changing somebody's life so anyway I'm
feeling great about things right now I'm
really I'm and I feel like I'm just
starting I call you I've been telling
everybody Gary Vaynerchuk Vaynerchuk is
the no threads feel it really feels like
I know you put the D in there I know all
the time you know Gary Vaynerchuk is no
I know extra Dominus of trends yeah do
you feel that way I don't because I
think Nostradamus first of all I
actually want to be Nostradamus because
he did really cool [ __ ] like if I was
Nostradamus here's what I would say in
2097 the red-headed will do the thing
and then and then what we do in 2097 is
like oh the Mao and explode it's a
volcano that's what he meant by redhead
like so he was so general that we like
now some of the SH is not you know it's
funny I got super freaking into
Nostradamus in fifth and sixth grade
like I didn't care about school at all
but one day like on a rainy day they
like brought in the [ __ ] TV with the
VHS and they played Nostradamus and I
was like who the what the [ __ ] this is
amazing I got really into it I don't
think I'm that here's what I do think I
am I so the reason I interrupt people so
much when I interview on my podcast is
cuz my brain goes too fast and like I
know what's happening I know it's not
like I have a sixth sense like I know
what you're about to say or you say one
word and I already know your sentence so
I'm like let's get to the next ship but
the audience is like yo [ __ ] what
was he gonna say so what I think I'm
very good at is is seeing trends very
quickly and acting on them they've
happened but for some reason nobody's
seeing it and I am and I'm acting on and
speaking to it and so it feels like it I
just think that I'm able to decipher big
data and social things a little bit
quicker than most
okay so you run Joe Rogan's podcast your
us interrupting the [ __ ] out it was I
you were and I was and I was his shelves
yeah and I was like damn what's up like
a man just interrupting the king of
conversation and then I look back I'm
like damn dude Gary was on to something
now do you still have a relationship
with some of the top podcasters yeah Los
Angeles and do you ever try to make it
make your way back on the circuit or
you're just too busy I'm too busy like
Joe I really wanted to do that show he's
got the best show mm-hmm he's killing it
we we DM each other once in a while have
some love what was like what did you see
that I was on to well I just knew that
this guy um knows he is so confident
because this is actually probably the
first six months I ever knew who the
hell Gary Vee was and so it was cool
that I was right about McGregor and
Mayweather well that was cool as [ __ ]
yeah because yeah that'll be fun like
nine years from now when somebody
listens to it and be like oh [ __ ] it's
fun now but you're just so tapped in and
and there's a difference between being
right and being narcissistic you know
I'm sure I only talk about [ __ ] I know
look if you're really gay you want to
talk about this apricot you're eating
right now or a peach river [ __ ] I'm
eating
I'd be like sure and you be like talk
about a bit it's delicious
you're like you know the pit comes from
the Apple II I be like I you would just
hear me quiet because I have nothing
else to say I think the thing that is
happening with me is I'm talking about
and I'm being interviewed by people
talking about the [ __ ] that I know that
I'm gonna be on tilt but if you want to
talk about poker right now you'd be
stunned how quiet I be I don't have to
play it I mean I know how to play it but
not like all you [ __ ] that grew up on
the internet and really not a play you
know like I I am actually where I think
I'm my most fun to watch because it's
might not my normal self is couples
dinners where like you know where I want
to be socially like a good like
partner-in-crime to the six couples so
I'm purpose of Caleb and a significant
other and my wife and I went out I'd be
like talk to significant never be like
what do you do and she's a lawyer he's
learned like you know you know that I'll
listen for 30 minutes
and I think that yeah I mean I think on
Brogan or anything else if I know what
I'm talking about like I was cutting him
off cuz he was wrong that he said the
McGregor and Weymouth mayweather if I
wouldn't happen I said it would and so I
get excited I was right where were you
at when you definitely bought that fight
yeah but that by um I was in the
Hamptons cuz it was summer right yeah
mm-hmm mm-hmm you're in the eight or
nine guys I was at my home and it was
fun actually his first four three four
rounds got us a little going right it
was a lot of fun I was I was very
neutral which was weird I don't I'm not
usually neutral it makes sense those two
[ __ ] made me neutral like I was kind
of like whatever I was like in a lot of
ways like love/hate with both of them I
don't really know either one of them but
uh I have a lot of empathy and like
curiosities around both of them cuz
we're unique dudes and so it was fun to
watch
personality-wise would you consider
yourself the mayweather mcgregor of
business yeah I'm sure I mean I can't
kind of get away from that it's you
you're McGregor a business dawg you're
just McGregor has branded himself and
catapulted himself here's the thing to
the likes we've never seen here's the
thing I think I'm more Drake and I'll
explain what I mean by that Greg is
self-deprecating and and deploys
humility yeah so I think I'm a little
more drakey though you know I haven't
looked enough Mayweather doesn't do
humility or self deprecation so I
definitely know that McGregor seems to
have that in him I just have a right
it's a little bit a little bit so I
think that makes the most sense but I
think I'm much more great like um I'm
really comfortable in my shortcomings
and I like them and I like talking about
them because I think I'm the greatest of
all time and I think I mean nothing and
I think that's balance extreme balance
which I why I think I'm gonna have
extreme results I really think I can be
the most heralded entrepreneur of this
generation I do not think I'll make more
money or even kind of business impact
than sucks or Bezos or Elon Musk
or many others but I think I'm gonna
touch the most entrepreneurs emotionally
create the most entrepreneurs help the
most entrepreneurs help the most people
not to entrepreneurship and I think
that's gonna be a big legacy it makes
sense when you when Drake's new albums
named scorpion yeah is he a Scorpio oh
no he's an October baby right yeah yes
yep
that's kind of like mile Eminem a mile
hundreds out there me too like I always
do that right you know it's funny I
don't put myself in a lot of risky spots
mmm the sneaker was fun because I put
myself in a risky spot like that could
have been a real [ __ ] flop like when
I was sitting about that was like I
remember one flight I was just like dude
you're a Scorpio hat that's kind of cool
it's like the whole full circle yes tom
I remember one flight and that was fun I
was like okay this could get ugly like
they may not sell any they may be like
in the dollar store closed out like this
could be stupid I felt confident but I
knew I was going and that that was a
leap that that was like huh and that
made that exciting but it felt so
natural right to me so I felt confident
yeah have you ever just had a fateful
instance where you're like damn
something higher than myself is talking
to me right now I kind of feel like
never and always mm-hmm you know almost
like just flowing out I could feel like
they're so like look here's what I would
say I take no I am the byproduct of my
parents in my environment
hmm so I don't think of myself excuse me
about the sneeze and this is a really
good sneeze if you're Russian you know
why I just got excited
in the Russian superstition when you
sneeze when you're saying something it
means that it's very true so it's really
interesting to me that I was just about
to say I don't get high on my own supply
I don't think I'm special not because I
don't think I'm special like I know I'm
having special results I just think
that's the cosine to my parents and
America and adversity not me
vaynermedia I get excited about I mean I
did that my kids one day I'll be like yo
but like me that's my parents and and
the year I grew up in and like coming
from nothing and circumstance and so
like when people like you're when people
like you're Jesus
like you walk on water I'm like cool I I
thank you oh my god but like cool when
people like you're a charlatan you're
full of [ __ ] you're snake oil says my
cool like it's just it's all quiet in my
head it's super quiet in my head as
promoters of Gary Vaynerchuk and
disciples of Gary Vaynerchuk so often
throughout this process Gary I heard I'm
not gonna come to that I can go on
YouTube and already here and I know you
I know you talk about this don't watch
my [ __ ] you don't need to if you're
already doing it but when people should
come see live entertainment when it
comes to dude you gotta grab Tony
Robbins live that's when you get the
goods
whether he's saying the same [ __ ] or not
what do you say to people like that I
think that's a personal thing like I
have a lot of empathy of like how you're
thinking about event marketing and
things of that nature but the truth is
go to people who want it yeah I would
tell you don't sell to the unsellable
hmm like we don't need the clip here and
be like so you get it like me saying
come to live events if that's not the
kind of way you learn hmm look the
reason to come to a Gary Vee event is to
network with the other [ __ ] in the
place like you you're around other
people that are hungry and trying to win
you [ __ ] yeah yeah like yeah there you
go man like until like that's the ROI
like after everybody pours out and goes
to the streets of Rochester or whatever
the [ __ ] you guys do around here like
you know like let go [ __ ] do [ __ ]
like meet people like people gonna hang
around and do stuff and like you know
and then also the cool thing about that
is like the Rolling Stones are like
Aerosmith and like Billy Joel and to
beat like the Beatles performed a
trillion times but there is the Shea
Stadium event like like this could be
the night that like I do say the thing
or that like my whole legacy is known
for and then if I get cool and big one
day that's cool right like the reason to
go to a concert is like they may play a
song a certain way or somebody may come
out and jam with somebody that they've
never jammed with before right like or
Jerry Garcia will just show up from the
dead
I don't know like something will happen
and I think that you know to me if I
loved keynotes and business or me the
reason I would come out is is you know
there was a time where I said what's the
ROI of your mother or stop watching
[ __ ] lost and if you're a hardcore me
fan and you were there the time it was
dropped that's cool the same way I would
go to a wrestling match
I know macho man is gonna beat you know
Georgie animal Steele every time but it
might be the night that he brings out
his new flying elbow version and so
what's so cool about live is you
actually don't know mm-hmm that's why
we've done you know this could be the
night somebody comes to run up and like
sure like hates me and I knock them out
with a right hook and it's amazing it's
like a you know like you just never know
and I think that's why you go live he's
so athletic yes so [ __ ] jack ya know
but that's kind of like when Prince died
our icon are our lifeblood here in the
lands of 10k when Prince died that
weekend if you wouldn't saw a live music
that weekend bro
the purple rains will never be the same
like a Dave Matthews Band over Super
Bowl weekend just the omage they were
playing or I saw Dave arm though we love
Dave Matthews I do I do
he's your favorite I mean period artist
growing up um no dude I grew up on I
love hip-hop but I grew up on mmm
obviously but I grew up on classic rock
dude it was Pink Floyd it bossed I get
on but the weekend that Rick James died
uh-huh that was arguably one of the best
Dave Matthews Band concerts to be at
because they played super freak and they
made it extra funky you know and it's
it's moments like that where it's like
that's why that's why live can always
play and and even when it's not extra
funky if you love [ __ ] Dave Matthews
but not really and let me explain what I
mean mine isn't if you love Dave
Matthews in this version which is you
see Dave Matthews Band three or four
times in your life you want to hear
satellite you know cuz you're a fake
Dave Matthews fan if you're a real Dave
Matthews fan you want to see what I'm
not my wife is ironically you want to
hear some other [ __ ] real [ __ ] like
some nerd [ __ ] right see when I go out
there right now the
gonna be fans there's not as many as
named Matthew but a hundred people that
are hardcore fans that 80 of them are
hardcore quote-unquote they just want to
hear me curse
they just think that's awesome the ones
that a really hardcore like is he gonna
go more into the parenting thing tonight
is even go social media like they know
they know that like you know and so I
think that's cool like I went years
spending the first ten minutes of my
keynote talking about Russia baseball
cards lemonade stands I don't do that
anymore
not because I think I've made it but I
think enough of a percentage of the
audience has heard it on YouTube
that I want to bring them value that's
why I only want to do Q&A
I just wanted Q&A is amazing cuz I'm
given all sorts of [ __ ] that I never
give you keep put me in QA I can bring
up new content in perpetuity it wouldn't
be a stationary astronaut podcast Carrie
if I didn't ask you this one how many
episodes have there been at the station
area that's what you are episode 104
what was that one episode one was just
me and my two co-hosts at the time
episode who was the biggest guess you
had before me oh [ __ ] I James Arthur Ray
the co-writer of the secret episode 99
what they say about the secret cuz I
think these secret scares I've never
read it so I [ __ ] on it dude but this
notion of like thinking and will happen
scares me because I think some people
think like lay on this couch right here
thinking it will happen it got culty it
got very cold you see admit to that or
is he or is he in there yeah he does he
actually cuz he went through some
tribulation doc did he calm yeah where
he was running a retreat and a few
people died under his watch right right
in the heat there in the heat sweat
lodge yeah so we got have to do that God
like beef with Oprah it was all weirder
that dude yeah yep
yeah it got crazy so I got into that and
I was I was hammering and that was my
first ever phone call interview on on
the podcast and it got crazy man so I
was asking him will you ever push sweat
lodges again not no I can't do it you
know so again is what Lodge good um it
actually pushes your neurotransmitters
in your brain you know what's the best
part for me is I failed everything in
science like I'll never do slick [ __ ]
like that only because like I don't even
I don't know you know what I mean like
when I hear that I'm like what's a
[ __ ] norm trans like I'm like I'm out
have you ever taken a psychedelic now
I've never [ __ ] smoked a cigarette
really that's the best [ __ ] about me
yeah that for me that makes me and my
family and like dear friends laugh my
college friends whose entire four-year
admission was to get me to take one puff
of a blunt and couldn't pull it off when
they see people leave comments in my
youtubes of like cokehead they like
sometimes screenshot and they send it to
me they're like this is such funny [ __ ]
you're so [ __ ] the worst we couldn't
get you to [ __ ] take one hit of one
blunt [ __ ] if these people knew that
you do nothing like you don't even drink
redbull they're like they would [ __ ]
believe any of us we just laugh about it
damn do ya man so you're the real deal
no I don't think I'm the real deal as a
matter of fact with Aubrey and Ferris
and all these [ __ ] I'm like I think
they're right yeah
like I think taking some weird [ __ ]
like grassy like rude like a banana peel
from the [ __ ] Amazon and it send you
into another dimension is like smart I
just don't want to do it like but I
think it's like I'm very like into it
actually like theoretic you know how
honest I feel about that steroids I
think people should do steroids mm-hmm
like I actually like kind of logically
now let me preface this because it's all
on the record I'm not educated at all
but there's something that feels
intuitively right to me that like the
forty five-year-old average male may
just want to take steroids I think
that's a good idea
I'm desperately hoping that self
awareness and self esteem get mapped as
a chemical and everybody can just inject
the [ __ ] out of it if we can inject the
[ __ ] out of self-esteem into every
person on earth everything would be fine
you wouldn't be mad at [ __ ] anybody
if you had full self-esteem you'd be mad
at no one nobody who's brown nobody
who's black nobody who's a woman nobody
who's a white male nobody who's in
Alabama in New York LA conservative
liberal like we'd all be chill if
everyone's like me I love everybody
unless you're a dick then I hate you and
that's what self esteem is and [ __ ]
that's the [ __ ] drug [ __ ] a mushroom
that makes you want to have sex longer
like let's get some [ __ ] self-esteem
going here if I [ __ ] stick a
self-esteem up your ass you'll [ __ ]
dominate life
so maybe that's [ __ ] what's up like
let's start talking about self-esteem
that's the [ __ ] drug aman like
ritalin coke crack like all this speed
like what people think i'm on that [ __ ]
doesn't do anything that's [ __ ]
short-term i'm long-term you want
long-term it's self esteem and empathy
be kind and like have compassion and
also [ __ ] have compassion for
yourself and be like know that you're a
winner
like find your [ __ ] like don't listen
the [ __ ] the people that [ __ ] on you
like get in your own head put positivity
around you drop loser friends like don't
hang out with losers if your mom's a
loser get the [ __ ] out of there if your
buddy from around the way
like I believe in loyalty the most I'm
not [ __ ] guy more than anybody but
guess what if your buddies a [ __ ]
loser and just thinks the government and
society like you gotta have to drop them
you have to hang out with them once a
year not a freakin [ __ ] day and like
let's start having mental talk boom and
that's what we're doing tonight yes
thank you for coming Gary welcome to the
stationery astronaut thank you man
thanks for having me si all right si
baby you're going on stage in literally
two minutes while I'm primed
[Music]